il se passer comme nos jours il parle
trop ça qu'ils s'expriment 'tweet' il
fait des déclarations d'abord te blesses
à leurs portes aux pieds elle était
sympa de nous répondre en tout cas non
mais c'est ce que je dis c'est pour
défendre c'est que le propre de ce
garçon c'est qu'il passe son temps à
parler et à dire parfois des bêtises ou
pour faire une bonne une bonne balle ou
pas et qu'à chaque fois ça leur tombe
dessus pour le coup je peux vous dire
une chose c'est que il ya de fortes
chances que il porte le chapeau pour
effectivement pour beaucoup de gens mais
c'est possible c'est possible c'est dit
c'est un peu injuste aires quittée le
monde sedin et c soit aujourd'hui on a
plein lui il prend pour tout le monde
c'est moi je trouve profondément et
revient à parler après oui mais d'accord
toujours pas ce que lui ont faite les ça
ne me choque pas puisqu'il dénonce est
située la situation dans laquelle on est
et après sur les politiques s'emparent
les deux ministres parce que ça je ne
sais pas les politiques dans les
restaurants saint secret de polichinelle
ça fait demba diop
ça fait des mois qu'on sait qu'à des
politiques de premier plan qui vont dans
des restaurants mais qui était mal voire
pas de ministres honnêtes honnêtement à
ma connaissance mais moi j'ai entendu
plein de fois et j'ai même vu des
politiques aller dans les restaurants
c'est toujours comme ça on nous dira
qu'il est le premier plan contient des
anciens présidents de premier plan
mais le canard enchaîné qui avait sorti
effet tiennent un restaurant et bfm il y
avait fauché oui tout le temps fort si
on n'a pas beaucoup parlé pareil moi
aujourd'hui j'ai essayé de savoir
franchement j'ai trouvé trace d'aucun
ministre non seulement chez pierre jean
chalencon mais modestement j'ai essayé
j'ai eu nulle part wendel moment donné
ça va piquer votre quart des voix là et
j'ai pas eu trace de ministres guillaume
dans des restaurants clandestins quel
qu'il soit après benjamin vous êtes
durée de chalencon parce que lui parlent
et s'expriment on l'interrogé répond il
dit sa vérité
roger déclaré l'allemand la magie
déclaratoire fellini choi dit oui bon je
mange avec des ministres et d'une
connerie après dénommées d'une connerie
il avait le feu aux poudres